la vague au micron en bourbe les
urgences chinoises une trentaine de
malades sont alités à l'hôpital de la
ville de siane ce patient est encore
dans un état grave après un passage aux
soins intensifs souligne ce médecin
ou tout a commencé fin 2019 les fils
s'allonge à l'hôpital aux abords duquel
on est riche de nouvelles salles de
quarantaine le déconfinement isole de
plus en plus la Chine sur la scène
internationale
l'Australie est la dernière en date
imposer des restrictions au passagers
qui arrivent de Chine
Ottawa a annoncé samedi que les
voyageurs en provenance de Chine devront
présenter un test négatif avant le
décollage dès le 5 janvier une décision
motivée par le manque de données
épidémiologiques c'est pas
nécessairement pour avoir un impact
majeur sur la transmission de la covid
au Canada mais c'est surtout pour
prévenir l'é l'importation de nouveaux
variants la Chine traverse une période
difficile reconnaît le président chinois
l'abandon de la politique zéro covid en
décembre devait permettre la réouverture
de son économie mais le Fond Monétaire
International prévoit que cette flambée
des cas Vienne freiner la croissance
chinoise et mondiale pendant quelques
mois les gens vont rester davantage chez
eux vont être davantage malades donc il
faut s'attendre à ce que dans les
prochaines semaines c'est pas les
prochains mois l'économie ralentisse
dans un rare geste d'ouverture Taïwan
tend la main à Pékin pour combattre la
vague épidémique malgré la constante
menace militaire chinoise
la présidente taïwanaise justifie son
offre sur la base de préoccupation
humanitaire pour aider plus de gens à
sortir de la pandémie et ainsi avoir une
nouvelle année en santé et en sécurité
ici Jean-Philippe news Radio-Canada
Montréal